hello guardians destiny's expansion the
dark below is now been out for about a
day and it turns out there's actually a
ray chest that you can get yourself
similarly to the ray chest in the vault
of glass that was right before the
gorgon's maze
what you want to do is go from the spawn
point go left hug the wall until you get
to a passage here where a door actually
opens
now if you're lucky the chest will
actually be there
but it doesn't always spawn there so if
it's not there what you want to do is
run into the thralls let them kill you
respawn
rinse and repeat go look again if it's
not there die again
if you do find it loot it and
subsequently tell your friends because
they can also join your fire team and
get the loot as well
make sure to take advantage of this as
you can get radiant energy radiant
shards maybe an exotic and also a raid
class armor
stay tuned to gamespot for continuing
coverage of the dark below
you